action shown one of the most popular
genres in anime as a whole I love it and
I know you do too but what about those
who are just new to the channel or those
newcomers to anime looking for new stuff
to watch that's what this list is mainly
for I'll be listing what I feel ended up
being my top 10 favorite actions Shonen
from the year 2020 until now and if
you're already updated with the latest
shows maybe you want to stick around and
see if your favorites that started in
the past few years get a shout out
[Music]
starting off at number 10 is Darwin's
game
foreign
[Music]
things up with something that's right
from the start of 2020 a season that I
call the Calm before the storm right
before all hell broke loose amongst the
numerous Survival game Battle Royale
series that seemed to pick up for a
short while a few years ago Darwin's
game ended up being one of my favorites
alongside gleibeneer shout out to that
one too Darwin's game has a simple
premise but I think it ended up being
one of its strengths there's no super
deep narrative or anything but I didn't
need to have one it presented us with a
lot of cool characters with creative
applications for their powers juking it
out in Crazy battles and that's what
really matters the most the main cast
have their own charms and a quirky
Dynamic all without the over-the-top ax
Crazy World Views that these kind of
shows tend to employ on their leads
while there's much to be explored with
the World building once it's all said
and done Darwin's game makes for a nice
easy watch if you're up for urban
fantasy action along with a dash of
violence the show doesn't break any new
ground but it doesn't need to especially
when its main themes and points involve
giving its audience satisfaction action
through the displays of fighting in
camaraderie
Eden zero is number nine on the list
[Applause]
[Music]
even before it started airing there was
a lot being said about Eden zero most of
them from with an air of cynicism it's a
running joke to call this show Fairy
Tale in space and I really don't blame
anyone who does do that heck I even
found myself having some cheap laughs at
Eden Zero's expense earlier on however
the show itself ended up being pretty
good and I can confidently say that it's
heading towards becoming one of Hiro
mashima's best work so far Eden zero
takes the standard adventure to search
for something gives it a Sci-Fi flavor
and they'll surprisingly deeply into the
character aspect that makes such a story
work sure I'm not claiming Eden zero is
some hidden Masterpiece in terms of
character writing but there's really
some potential to be had especially
given mashima's reputation in his
previous Works overall there's something
magical and genuine in this adventure
that makes the audience want to keep
following the journeys of Shiki and
Rebecca and it's one of the most Vivid
examples of an author improving on his
previous works
moving from sci-fi to Supernatural
fantasy we have kimono jihin
foreign
is one of the shows that I was very
excited for entering the winter 2021
season exiting That season I do think
it's one of the underrated hits from
then overshadowed by the likes of
mushoku tensei and its super strong
lineup of sequels kimono jihen settles
into its niche as a dark Shonen focusing
on the emotional aspects and its
characters which help carry the show
there's action in Spades yes and any
veteran on anime wouldn't find anything
unique in the whole mutants or Monsters
living amongst people set up but I
barely think that either of that's the
main ingredient which makes this series
work when looking at kimono jihen thinks
something more like Doro in terms of
overall feel compared to the major
mainstream hits there's still the whole
Supernatural aspect that can make it a
success with the audience but the story
takes things in a slight detour opting
to lean more on the mature themes that
invite its audience to introspection
it's truly a Hidden Gem that's
understandably overshadowed if you're up
for an action shown in with the familiar
Supernatural setting but a really strong
emphasis on character and emotional
Stakes kimono jihin may be worth your
shot
all right
Ronnie Kenshin is up next
with including this one Rooney Kenshin
is by no means a new anime if we
consider that it's a remake unlike the
rest of the shows that I featured on
this list however since it is a remake
we can't treat it as a new entry and
that's fine since I want to tell you how
this remake impressed me a lot I've long
been a fan of the classic Rurouni
Kenshin and this 2023 remake has
basically encapsulated what I imagined a
modern retelling of the Legendary
Classic to actually be like there's some
good build up to the story nice pacing
so far and the Schumer's still on point
there have been some changes and the new
voice acting has taken a while to get
used to but overall this is pretty much
a remake to look out for when I was
getting excited about this series and
looking forward to how it will help
usher in some new fans to the franchise
this is what I'm talking about it's
still quite early to his run but we'll
see how it goes moving forward for now
this gets my pick as one of the top
Shonen for recapturing the magic of the
original while giving it a Fresh coat of
paint for the modern times
this
Tokyo Revengers marks our approach to
the halfway point
huh
time Loop stories have been quite
popular for a long time but they seem
confined to more mature Target audiences
with the likes of Steins Gate maroka and
re-zero amongst others thus it felt
fitting for a battle-oriented Shonen
series to take a crack at the concept
Tokyo Avengers takes that time Loop
premise and adds a rugged
battle-oriented feel to it and it just
works while people often see battles
Shonen as a genre that's full of the
Supernatural and magical battles Tokyo
Revengers remains relatively true and
grounded with a gritty reality of gang
Warfare not to say that the show is
realistic or anything like that but
comparing it to its popular peers which
seems to be mostly geared towards
fantasy Tokyo Avengers does carve a
pretty unique Niche for itself it's a
show that's simply full of Hot Blooded
moments to get you all pumped up with
adrenaline Tokyo Avengers has great
fights memorable characters and a good
serving of character drama along for the
ride it's not surprising that the series
has quickly gained momentum and
popularity and if the feel of the series
appeals to you you should really give
this one a try
and if you're enjoying this video why
don't you try hitting that like And
subscribe Button as well I'd really
appreciate it let's talk about try gun
stampede
in the same vein as Kenshin from a while
ago we once again take a look at a
reimagination of a Timeless classic try
again didn't feel like it had the same
level of cultural impact where only
Kenshin had back in the day but it had
just as strong of a foundation with its
story and characters and with this
modern version try gun Stampede I'm
pleased to see that a lot of what I
liked about classic Trigun returned
there's a shift in focus for Trigun
Stampede with it placing a lot of
emphasis on the main protagonist as a
result it becomes more of a
character-oriented piece of work and I
think he works pretty well for both OG
fans and people coming into trying to
see what the buzz is all about don't let
the implications of being a
character-oriented work throw of your
expectations however since Trigun
Stampede still has a lot of other things
that make shows in the genre work
immersive fights some comedy and an
interesting World think of this as a
modern take on Trigun that's quite
similar from the original yet carrying
its own charm with its overall
modernized look and change in main focus
there's some CG that might deter people
but I guarantee it'll be a good watch
for fans of action Shonen hi
if you're up for something super
light-hearted however you'll like this
next entry Marshall
foreign
something really Charming with what I
feel is a new take on the whole one
punch man Trend secret overpowered
character entering a world where he gets
to Showcase his skills in some of the
most over-the-top ways possible there's
always a market for these kinds of
parody shows and among them I do think
that Marshall is one of the better ones
from the recent years where the martial
clicks with you is largely dependent on
how much you adore the concept of dumb
fun it's not going to win any awards in
terms of being super original but the
execution is very well done it's really
chill it's got pretty cool animation and
this is a show that knows its identity
and does a great job in pushing what it
does well if you're a fan of something
like a psyche or one punch man and want
to capture the feeling of loving those
kinds of shows then this is surely
something to keep in your crosses in the
whole over-the-top fun Department it's
one of the best in recent memory
nope
[Music]
the next title ain't no laughing matter
however welcome to the world of of
Hell's Paradise
[Music]
foreign
and the light-hearted fun hell's
Paradise takes us to a grim and
treacherous world but of dangers at
every corner yet carries with itself a
sense of mystical Wonder that's exactly
the feel that the manga intended and the
anime adaptation to this fast rising
action adventure story nailed that
atmosphere to a t Hell's Paradise is
quickly becoming one of the best Shonen
titles to see us debut the past three
years and it just keeps getting better
and better hell's Paradise may not have
become a runaway mainstream success that
had even non-anime fans going Gaga or
singing its opening with a show in
itself exudes a unique kind of artistic
energy instead of falling in line with
the more mainstream hits house Paradise
kind of finds itself in the territory
where I place kimono jihin previously
the darker more methodical type of
Shonen that carries an artistic Flair as
more expected of a cult classic it's got
a lot of the thrilling fights in the
world it's beautifully crafted and full
of intrigue it sure is a joy seeing a
lot of anime fans experiencing the
series you should join the party too
thank you
chainsaw man then takes those cue points
and pushes it to another level
when it comes to unhinged violence dark
and devilish appeal and questions
regarding morality chainsaw man takes
those themes into overdrive with that
kind of appeal it's not surprising that
the show ended up being one of the
biggest hits of 2022 for anime fans
especially given that it's part of a
demographic intended for younger more
impressionable audiences to see
something as for adults in air quotes in
the way it portrays its characters or
battles or to turn some eyes and it did
so in a big way chainsaw man oozes Rebel
energy from the way it looks to the
opening themes the fighter Insanity
personified and they do such an
excellent job in keeping people talking
and watching week in and week out I do
think that the one thing holding
chainsaw man back from the mainstream is
how it's not universally appealing it's
way easier to introduce your family to
something like a Demon Slayer for
example but going that route will lose
chainsaw manit identity instead it feeds
into the whole Rebel energy I talked
about and firmly erects its signature
foothold in the Shonen sphere
big
all right
lastly I have Jiu Jitsu Kaizen as my top
pick for new Shonen of 2020 to 2023.
it's really easy putting Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen here and at the top of this list
not only is it one of the most popular
Shonen hits It's got elements that
epitomize what a quintessential era
defining Shonen is like breathtaking
fights a simple plot that's got a lot
more going on underneath the surface an
interesting and creative Powers it's no
wonder that this show has quickly taken
its place as one of the most popular
titles and deservingly so animation and
fight choreography mainly take Center
Stage amongst the things that people
praise when it comes to jiu jitsu Kaizen
and while that's not misplaced I would
also love to bring attention to the
really fun character Dynamics the show
boasts in my opinion the chemistry
between members of the cast is such an
important part of making a battle Shonen
great and something that this show has
that just doesn't get talked about as
much as the animation Jiu Jitsu Kaizen
knows its audience and what they want as
well as the character tropes of the
battle shown in genre it feeds in those
elements only to add some twists along
the way to keep them pretty fresh it
also masterfully integrates the horror
elements and darker aspects without the
dark and edgy feeling too overwhelming
thus helping maintain the series Mass
Appeal which I think is yet another
underrated point that I just love about
the show it's too hasty to Crown it King
of the genre this early but seeing Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen take the lead in the 2020s
generation of battles Shonen gives me
confidence that the genre is in good
hands
and that certainly is a way to wrap up
today's list now that's my list but what
does your list look like do tell me what
you feel are the best Shonen titles that
made their debut in the past three years
as always I'm inviting you to check out
the channel for more videos and you may
like or join us through our social media
with the links in the description box
thanks for watching and I hope you liked
the video have a good day ahead and I'll
be seeing you next time